je m'appelle marché levien g92 rosa
j'habite à 7 hectares à la maison et
amis des ide ans pour personnes âgées
cet avis situé tout près de mont-joli
c'est inquiétant et c'est tintin
campagne à peu près 500 habitants ça me
plaît ici parce que je suis tranquille
juste une personne de campagne j'ai même
pensé me reprocher de bilan mais je fait
un show nous ici puis je me sens bien
très bien et j'écoute de la musique je
lieu je fais dit tricot la couture
il fait ce genre de chose pour que ça
fonctionne le cerveau mal la solitude
c'est mon ami j'avais moins un cheval
d'arçons exigeante et j'espère jamais
plus que ce que j j'espère que le bon
dieu me laisse ça sent un peu de champ
tekori et le courage que j'ai si ce que
j'espère moi